d
un éco village c'est un lieu de vie
c'est un lieu de partage et pour moi
c'est un lieu qui devrait se propager
vraiment partout
et s'il n'y avait rien du tout c'était
la forêt y avait juste un sentier de
petite randonnée ici qui faisait 60 cm
de large et puis on a commencé à
défricher à couper les arbres à couper
de déjeuner à couper des herbes et puis
petit à petit on si on s'y est implanté
le dimanche il y avait souvent la
famille qui venait avec le grand-père la
grand mère les enfants tout ça pour
pourvoir les indiens si au début on nous
appelait comme ça dans la rue
s'installer dans la forêt vouloir vivre
à contre courant forcément ça interroge
quand alexis lançons projets
d'écovillages il y a dix ans on a
d'abord cru à une secte il y a même une
enquête
ici les cinq maisons du hameau se fond
dans le paysage
aucune trace de béton tous les matériaux
sont naturels alexis a construit sa
maison lui même avec une idée si elle
doit disparaître
il ne doit en rester aucune trace ou
presque tout doit retourner à la terre
j'ai coupé les arbres
j'ai fait les planches avec une scie
mobile on a fait le statut ravec
et puis on a rempli en bottes de paille
la passe et l'isolant parce que c'est un
des meilleurs isolants et c'est ça c'est
de la paille de senna paille de blé
on peut utiliser d'autres pas il met
enfin moi j'ai fait le choix de la
paille de blé et elle est dans les murs
et dans le plafond qui sait que la
paille isole parfaitement stockent la
chaleur ou la fraîcheur en fonction des
saisons écologique et surtout pas cher
parce que la paille c'est en déchets
agricoles
contrairement au point il ya des essais
qui ont été faits en laboratoire sur la
paille et les bottes de paille ils sont
allés au lance flammes
il ya des tanks ont été calculés avant
justement que ça access désagrège
complètement et tout mais ça se consume
c'est à dire par rapport à une maison en
conventionnel empare pas une maison en
paille mettra beaucoup plus de temps à
être détruites par le feu
contrairement aux idées reçues les trois
petits cochons donc même si la paille
c'est pas très cher le coût de la maison
est quand même important que c'est plus
important que pour une maison
conventionnelle parce que c'est pas des
techniques qui sont encore très connu
ben c'est pas des techniques très connu
mais il ya quand même une grande partie
des matériaux qui sont qui peuvent
rester cher parce que c'est pas des
matériaux qui sont attendus en très
grande quantité comme le le parpaing ou
le ciment et puis et puis il ya de la
beaucoup de main d'oeuvre
donc cette main d'oeuvre aussi peut
revenir très cher depuis quatre ans
alexis construit sa maison un peu chaque
jour et elle n'est pas tout à fait
terminé encore une vie en chantier qui
se construit lentement
c'est vrai que quand je suis énervé un
peu stressé c'est vraiment très agréable
de venir passer un petit moment ici
d'une part pour regarder pour pour
apprécier pour voir s'il n'y a pas de
graminées qui sont venus envahir par les
graminées je suis désolé mais je leur
laisse pas la place un jardin en hauteur
que tous les habitants cultivent sur
leur toit s'est inscrit dans la charte
du village on est parti sur l'idée de
dire si on rendait à la terre la surface
qu on lui prend donc de mettre des
plantes et des herbes et tout ça sur la
surface de la maison et puis bon
l'avantagé des toits végétalisés c'est
des problèmes de condensation aussi ça
évite la condensation dans la maison
mais il a fallu s'accrocher pour que le
éco-hameau voit le jour des années de
luttes administratives qui ont fini par
en décourager certains
thomas et sa femme ont racheté le
terrain d'un couple qui a quitté le
projet eux aussi ont vécu en ville
eux aussi ont eu envie de rompre de fuir
une vie qu'il ne maîtrisait plus envie
d'autre chose pour et pour leur fille
on n'a pas vécu les enfants ville on
arrive à la campagne avant heureusement
mais quand on y va on n'a pas les
réflexes dans un premier temps les uns
face bad à côté de nous et puis on se
rend vite compte qu'ils ramassent des
mégots par terre qui amasse plein de
choses on se dit bon qu'est ce que je
fais
je lui interdis ce que je lui interdis
pas à la maison ça c'est compliqué et
alors qu'ici bon même si elles mêmes
tout noir plein de terre ou debout c'est
jamais bien grave quoi l'habitat écolo
permet de dépenser moins
c'est ce qui est dans l'air du temps
mais pour thomas et mathilde ce n'est
pas ce qui compte c'est des gens qui se
tourne aujourd'hui vers l'éco
construction c'est aussi par cet
argument économique j'en suis très
content simplement il faut se méfier
quand même de ce que cette économie qui
va engendrer
à savoir tout l'éco business des
matériaux qui vont à nouveau être
transformée et oui les avoirs d'état
l'intermédiaire qui vous permettre
d'accéder à une maison écologique
c'était pas ça l'idée non plus ici c'est
pas du bois raboter c'est du bois brut
de sciage c'est de la paille brut de
deschamps essaie de la terre locale
également pour faire le torchis le pari
c'est celui de cohabiter ensemble et de
vivre en harmonie avec la nature
l'autre voisine sur laquelle tout le
monde veille alors comme une évidence
les habitants font en sorte de rendre à
la terre une eau propre grâce à un
bassins plantés de roseaux et d'iris
c'est les plantes elles mêmes qui se
nourrissent de l'eau et qui en même
temps récupère les commerces qui
les cochonneries qui sont dans l'eau ce
sont les bactéries fixés sur les racines
des plantes qui nettoie les impuretés
on appelle ça la phytoépuration ça
pollue en tout cas beaucoup moins bon à
mon sens en tout cas ça pollue moins
qu'une fosse sceptique parce qu'une
fosse septique si elle est vraiment pas
évident il fallait pas vidanger
convenablement finale est pas
entretenues comme il faut bien ça
devient une vraie source de pollution et
le drain toute façon les drains sans
cacher on nous c'est tout aussi tout à
vue donc s'il ya un problème on le sait
tout de suite déjà à loder et tout le
monde s'occupe des bassins à tour de
rôle c'est pas une très grosse
contrainte faut pas oublier quoi c'est
tout mais quand on oublie avec toujours
quelqu'un qui te dit tu as passé en bas
ça tu as réussi à arranger les choses
l'esprit collectif c'est ce qui a plu à
françoise lassé par le chacun pour soi
la vie en communauté elle a déjà connu
mais cette fois sa démarche n'est plus
la même
ce qu'on vit je pense ça montre que
n'importe qui peut le vivre n'importe
qui peut faire ça parce que bon nous on
a des voitures on travaille quand je
suis parti en communauté enfin en retour
à la nature c'était on refuse elle a
refusé la société alors que maintenant
en fait moi je suis institutrice donc je
suis vraiment dans la société et donc on
peut vivre comme on le fait là
finalement ce que chacun est venu
chercher ici c'est un coin de quiétude
de paradis loin très loin du tourbillon
qui laisse de côté ceux qui ne sont pas
dans le rythme
mais le vivre ensemble
c'est un apprentissage de tous les jours
alors régulièrement ils se retrouvent
pour tout mettre sur la table les soucis
matériels
les satisfactions les états d'âme je
voulais faire une maison écologique
mais bon je vais pas cette mentalité de
collectivités voilà on cherche tout le
temps le consensus c'est pas toujours
évident il y en a qui traînait des pieds
et puis bon finalement bon mais on y
arrive petit à petit on y arrive des
fois il ya des grincements de dents bah
oui à des réunions ça nous après
l'acceptation des différences aussi la
scène c'est plus que la tolérance et
l'acceptation de différence un couple de
parisiens viendra bientôt rejoindre l'
aventure un poulailler un four à pain
collectifs sont aussi en projet mais les
habitants veulent prendre leur temps
alors qu'ailleurs tout s'accélère ici on
a décidé de freiner et avant de vous
quitter j'aimerais partager avec vous
une citation de pierre rabhi il dit que
vivre sobrement c'est une forme de
libération je vous laisse méditer
à bientôt
hu